against the yankees he's been good this
year he's had a couple of starts against
the yankees he's undefeated
there's a base hit through the left side
of the infield the yankees lead off with
a single one down so here's labor
tourist
curveball on the ground
that's the second for one panic with the
turn not in time wasn't hit hard enough
to turn two but they get the force out
in seconds stan takes ball four so it'll
be first and second with two outs now
for geo urchella
they're off speed pitch and vladi makes
a nice play they get the force out of
second so no harm no foul pretty solid
numbers across the board for monty the
era to the fip is 3.99 era as you as you
saw is pretty solidly above average but
his fielder independent pitching's much
better than that actually it's 3.40
so montgomery starts the game with
back-to-back walks and that's not
exactly how you want to pitch with
flatty gorilla coming to the plate
fall four three straight walks issued by
montgomery to start to game and he has
loaded the bases to oscar hernandez this
season batting with the bases loaded is
four for six the oscar hits a high pop
up center field deep enough to score a
run gartner waits on it simeon's tagging
at third he was scored but shed will
move over to third and the oscar has
given to blue jays an early lead here's
randall grichik swung on a high pop in
the infield
chris gittins underneath off first he
makes the catch in there two-way uriel
has his average up to 263. he gets out
of this with one run that's that's
really an accomplishment
swung on a little chopper to the mound
montgomery underhands the first
and jordan after he dug his own grave
walking the first three men was splendid
one nothing toronto we hit the second
inning and the yankees send up six seven
and eight here's six gary sanchez now
here is ryu's two-two swing-on hit high
in the air to left it is high it is far
it is gone and it went over the screen
and out of the ballpark whoa
the kraken
cracks one sanchez who's been red-hot
connects for his ninth home run of the
year had a 1-1 game one down now that'll
bring to the plate the left-handed
hitting center fielder brett gardner
another 2-2 pitch
got him little cutter right there as
gardner strikes out so it's first and
second two outs and an o2 count on aaron
judge
he goes around
falling into dirt brilliant will go to
first to complete the strikeout and ryu
gets a couple of strikeouts at the end
of an inning and a half which i'd won
the rookie catcher is up riley adams
struck him out swinging chains beautiful
good looking change up fading down and
away it just doesn't get there you can
see how far out in front the bat head is
on that changeup one one ball game as we
head to the third so there's one away so
stanton walks for a second time that's
four walks already issued by yen jin ryu
so here's her shella
come out
as geo rochelle bounces into an inning
ending double place over you after
another walk gets the double play to end
the inning now we go to the bottom of
the third inning well we should lean
things off for the blue jays 13 homers
and 39 rbis 13 homers a new career high
was after the first pitch and hits it
into the air deep right center gardener
back looking up goodbye home run
both the ship goes opposite field for
home run number 14 and abujas have taken
a 2-1 lead that's the fifth time this
season that he has hit a first pitch
home run there is guerrero
strike three right down the middle
guerrero down looking two-way here is
randall griechuk half swinging a slider
in the dirt he went
and that'll take care of the third
inning and at the end of thraining to
play two on toronto there's kittens
looking for his first big league hit
that one's a deep to left field
there it is
see ya
you're in the record books with a home
run his first of his career his first
big league hit and that ties the game at
two
chris kitten who is he he's chris
hard hidden goodness and he homers out
of the ballpark in left field and the
yankees have tied the game at two bottom
of the fourth inning with runners at
first and second and two men out here is
marcus simeon
bouncing boom bare handed attempt and
booted by torres the shortstop he was
playing in the shift really in the deep
part of shortstop and couldn't make the
play and now blue jays have the bases
loaded the number two batter in the line
of boba shed at the plate these homeward
are ready this evening
and that goes off of sanchez's glove and
the blue jays are going to score a run
this team is not a good defensive team
they don't run the bases well they make
a lot of mistakes and it is not a
typical new york yankee ball club will
cost them a run that should be a pass
ball that's a catchable ball two outs
runners on second and third
[Applause]
oh rips it into left here the run runs
coming in and they're gonna send the
second runner and here's simeon coming
to the plate he signs in safely ahead of
the throw
bo buchet
two more rbis that gives him three on
the night
and the blue jays have extended their
lead it's five cheer coming off a great
series where he hit over 400 in boston
he's been on base three times we go to
the top of the sixth as it is a double
for sanchez and it's second and third
with one man out well here is anduha
ball
to panic run scores
over the first so it's 5-3 an rbi for
and duhar and sanchez moves to third
santiago espinal knocks it down recovers
in time to end the inning getting hit it
hard well we go to the seventh and they
will send up gardner
that one is driven to right field and
deep going back is hernandez on the
track at the wall see ya a home run for
gardner
just over the wall and right and the
yankees creeped within one
so let the guardian party begin guardie
plants one in the right field seats and
the yankees now trailed 5-4 so the tying
run is now just 90 feet away
[Music]
he went right back to the slider and
threw that one over the strike zone and
gets judged to swing and miss well
here's gleber with a run over third the
tying run and one out
that one gets away from the catcher
and the scroll is tied at five does not
get the glove down as it skips
underneath so yeah that's a wild pitch
because it hit the dirt but i think
riley adams will tell you that he should
have blocked that and the yankees who
were down 5-2 have now knotted it at 5-5
guerrero at second hernandez at first
one man out 5-5 game bottom of the seven
his hit on the ground double play ball
to short flip the second one on to first
double play until the yankees turn one
and get out of the jam so stolen base
for wade and he's in scoring position
with the go ahead run so frazier pinch
hitting for gardner
head shortly
inside third and down the left-hand line
wade will score easily
for frasier it's a big pinch hit rbi
double gives the yankees a 6-5 lead a
little speed and thump of the yankee
bench frazier aggressive ready to hit
gets a good ball in the inner third with
his confidence comes more aggression and
that's a good thing for clint frazier
there's trouble in the bottom of the
eighth inning the bases are loaded for
beau beshet this could be the ball game
right here the pitch swung on and driven
to right there is judge to make the
catch and in the inning
so britain pitches in and out of trouble
no runs one hit three left you go to the
bottom of the ninth chapman is coming on
for the close last two times out chapman
has suffered the loss how about this
matchup vladie guerrero steps to the
plate with his club down by ones
soft ground ball is short
and they get guerrero for the first out
well one down here is tay oscar
hernandez
splitter was a little up in the zone but
he got him on the change of speed and
that will bring up
toronto down to their final out
grounded right side
and that'll do it as the yankees win 6-5
and that is a grown-up victory by the
new york yankees breaking a three-game
losing streak and you can file that
under they needed that